from today I guess um you're gonna see
me for at least a few weeks
um we're gonna cover
um like some more like super starting
algorithms and we're going to talk about
deep learning and then uh I'll pass on
to Chris to talk about Express learning
so so I think I'm going to be in charge
in the next three or four weeks
um
and I'm going to use the board partly
because I think there is a little bit
more memory on the board right like uh
like I can write you can you can review
things that I can see I I wrote like a
like 10 minutes ago even I don't know
whether that's you know the best for
everyone I think in the past I've
surveyed students and someone prefer the
board someone prefers the zoom the the
iPad so I'll give it a try uh with this
but any comments or any kind of
suggestions are welcome and we we're
open to change the format as well so
um but for today at least I'm going to
use the board
um and I think the the video is able to
capture the board almost the same as the
the
um the iPad I hope
um okay so
um okay so I'm going to talk about
um
the so-called generative
learning algorithms
so the next two lectures will be about
this
I'm going to Define what does it mean by
generative learning algorithms and there
are two type of General learning
algorithms that we are going to cover
one is called gaussian discriminative
analysis
I guess these are all new words that I
have to Define as I'm introducing these
things
GDA
and another type of algorithms
is called naive Bayes
okay so I guess let me get started so
um I'll start by defining what do I mean
by generative learning algorithms to
kind of Define these terms I think it's
useful to compare with what Chris has
introduced in the last two weeks so in
the last two weeks I think the type of
algorithms Chris introduced we call them
discriminated discriminative learning
algorithms
so discriminative
learning algorithms
so the reason we call them
discriminative learning algorithms is
the following so in some sense the
definition is that if you model
or you parametrize
the relationship the conditional
relationship of Y given X
then we call this discriminative
learning algorithms and I think you know
if you recall this is the the type of
algorithm the type of kind of models we
considered in the last two weeks right
so we model y as a linear function of X
maybe Y is linear function of X Plus
gaussian noise or maybe Y is linear
function of X Plus exponential family or
something like that right so for example
uh in the most General format in the
last two ways can be summarized as you
think of the X the Y given X parameters
where Theta this is a distribution of Y
given X parametric space Theta you write
this as some exponential family
exponential
there's some distributions in
exponential family
with some parameter with some input ETA
and this ETA is a linear function of X
right for example you can say this is a
gaussian distribution which means ETA
and that's just the standard linear
regression right so so this is why we
call them um discriminative learning
algorithms and today we're going to talk
about
a so-called generative version
generative learning algorithms
the the basic idea is that you are going
to model
or parameters
here model means is a word means
basically means parameterized or you
have a mathematical model
for the conditional for the drawn
distribution P of X comma y
a joint distribution of X and Y you know
using the simple chain rule you can
write this as x given y times Q of Y
so you model both these two quantities
is this the there's some light is
flashing right some should I
are you bothered by it or not I'm fine
with it just
okay no worries okay
um I think it flashes after every minute
or something uh anyway so you model the
drawing distribution by modeling each
part of this tool and particularly you
model the drawing distribution by
modeling the distribution of Y and the
distribution of X condition y 0 X and Y
are not symmetric Y is the label X is
the input and typically they'll have
very different meanings y could be
something like you know like the price
of the house and X is uh the features
the all like what you know about the
houses right so like the the square feet
you know the Lost size so and so forth
so
um and recall that axis the input
or the and and this is maybe something
like a label or some kind of class right
if you have classification this is about
cast class like maybe positive sentiment
negative sentiment
and so so basically this is the
distribution of the input given the
label and this is the distribution of
the label itself
and sometimes we also call this you know
a prior for the label a prior for
the class or the label
because this is what you believe like
for example suppose Y is one means
positive sentiment Y is zero means you
know negative sentiment right suppose
you are classifying the text then this
is a distribution over two labels where
positive and negative and this is the
the prior that you have for how many
positive examples all negative samples
uh are in your data set
and and then
um so after you uh you mode on paramax
this you can learn
these two distributions right you can
learn the distributions learn P of x and
y and p of Y we're going to say how do
we learn them and after you learn both
of this you are going to still solve the
classification problem your goal is
still the same you are trying to
classify you are still trying to compute
so this is the test time
you are still trying to compute for
example P of Y given X
right you're still trying to classify
what's the chance of each of the label
or you probably want to get the max of y
g Max you know we are going to talk
about exactly
um you care about
um but essentially you still care about
the relationship of Y uh conditional X
and how do you get this you get this by
base rule
foreign
meaning so recall that PO for example y
given X is equals to P of x given y
times P of Y
over P of x
so you know this quantity you know this
quantity
and
your you know this I'm assuming you
already learned this too right and how
do you know the denominator then you can
just write this as
the denominator is really just the uh
you take sum over y
P of x given y times P of Y
uh maybe just uh for the same quotation
let's call this y Prime
right so
so this is the the standard the
um
total law of probabilities when you
complete the marginal probability of P
of X used as the denominator and then
you also compute use these two volumes
um on the top
actually in many cases you don't
necessarily have to compute the PO Box
we will see exactly how it works but
roughly speaking after you know these
two things you can know uh after you
know x given Y and Y you can know y
gonna ask by doing some base rule
because
by the way feel free to stop me at any
point you know just to reach handle us
to speak
um maybe
first
it's good so let me repeat the question
is it true that the discriminative
learning algorithms cannot work on
non-iscriminal understand right um no I
think the discriminate learning
algorithms can also work with other
possible uh distributions here so as
long as you specify y given X and your
parameterize that by some parameter
Theta you can in theory you can still
learn them using similar type of
methodology I'm going to discuss the
methodology as well uh
um
um but if you have expanded family then
it's gonna be
um there are several benefits for
example you know Chris discuss this many
properties nice properties of
expenditure family if you don't have
them then
um you don't you cannot use those
properties you have to use something
else or you can you have to rely on
optimization or sometimes it's
challenging
um depending on the cases but in
principle you can you can have other
distributions here
yeah maybe let's just do this order yeah
yeah
this is just a general framework so the
difference between the two that I can
guess is
actually you will have parameters
because I'm going to parametrize these
two distributions and and learn them so
um yeah I'm going to talk about that as
well
foreign
so this is a yes so I'm also going to
discuss uh the differences you know why
like what's the high level differences
why you want to do this but I think it's
easier to discuss those you know once I
tell you a little more about concretely
how this works
um but so far
you are right basically this is a
somewhat seemingly Securities way to get
P of YG Max right it's not direct right
um
yeah I think I'm going to discuss
discuss that you know discuss the
differences you know probably later in
the lecture just because you know it's
easier when I have some examples
okay any other questions
oh would it be possible to write a
little bigger please oh sure yeah that's
a great suggestion I think that's
probably also useful for the recording
as well
um and also feel free to remind me again
because I this this happens to in the
past as well like every time after like
a few lectures I I stopped writing big
you know even after a few minutes
sometimes maybe
um
okay so this is just a very high level
introduction
um so and just uh so we're gonna talk
about two instantiations
of this general idea
so one is called this one so the
difference is it's really just in one
case it's a continuous ax and the other
case is discrete discrete X
so and this continuous guys look it's
called This is the gaussian discriminate
analysis and the discrete acts we are
going to focus on our application which
is the the span filtering
right so and today I think we're going
to mostly talk about the continuous case
and next lecture
um I'm going to talk about the the spam
filtering
all right so
so so now one example how how do we
instantiate this plant
um so
so for GTA
what you do is you say I'm going to
suppose
X in Rd
um I'm going to drop the convention
just because here I'm not going to use
the uh the bias at least you know in the
modeling part I'm not going to use the
bias
um don't worry too much about it you
know it's just though we don't have the
X series one I know it doesn't really
matter that much so
um and I'm so the main thing is I'm
going to assume
you can say this is assumption you can
say this is a modeling assumption I'm
going to assume P of x given y
is a gaussian
gaussian distribution
so what does that really mean that
really means that you write this you
know you say
x given Y is following some gaussian
distribution with some mean
and said Can converts and here note that
X is a high dimensional Vector so I'm
going to have a high dimensional
multivariate gaussian disclosure
so and we submit and be some covalent
Sigma
so
um I think it used like a uh it's
probably useful for me to briefly that
that word
um kind of digress a little bit to
briefly talk about some Basics about
Matic varied gaussian description these
are just some very quick review if you
haven't seen this
um but I'm assuming that you know
something about one-dimensional gaussian
distribution so just a very quick uh
digression so if you have a
multi-dimensional gaussian random
variable
foreign
so what happens is that you suppose you
have some random variable Z sample from
this gaussian distribution which means
mu and sigma covarian Sigma so here mu
is a d dimensional vector and sigma is a
matrix is the so-called covariance
Matrix
so and the definition so the property
you know you need to know is that
you know as the name suggests the
expectation of the Z is supposed to be
the mean of the uh the mean parameter
right so
and the covarence
of the random variable Z which is
defined to be the expectation of Z minus
expectation Z
times Z minus expectation Z transpose
this is you know
is the The covariance Matrix
so so this is how the you know you
generate the C from this gaussian
distribution parameters by these two
parameters mu and sigma and the the
resulting random variable Z would have
these two properties the mean is Mu and
covariance is sigma
and and you only need two set of
parameters to describe unique like a
gaussian distribution
um and you also know that
um
you also know the density of discussion
distribution so the density of
the gaussian distribution is something
like this I don't expect you to remember
the formula because I
now I remember it after I teach teachers
so many times but you know before I
taught it I don't think I remembered in
my graduate school
um but the the formula is that I'm not
sure whether you can see this
um something like this
um and here this is the
is the determinant
okay great I see some questions
um
sure maybe I'll start with the one
one what does the denominator say
what is the denominator
so this is 2 pi to the power of theta
over 2 and the determinant of Sigma so
power of half and I'll write even bigger
oh this is just the oh one why I'm doing
this oh this is just a definition of the
code bar in case you don't know the
definition
so thank you yeah
um yeah I'm just using that as a to
indicate this definition
um and and by the way this formula you
know I don't think we really have to
remember it um the most important thing
is we have a constant
times some exponential of some quadratic
form of Z
oh
Z is a vector yeah that's a good
question
so this is why this is a little more
complicated than God than than one
dimensional case right if you are
familiar with the randomizable case then
this will be still a scared of meal and
this will be a long neck together
sometimes people write a sigma square
right so and the sigma will be just the
um the uh
um so for one master case this is just a
virus and now it's the so-called coal
virus and I guess you know if you are
um so so in some sense if you look at
Sigma of i j
this is really just the the correlation
between this will be uh the expectation
of
z z I say the ice chord minus UI times
ZJ minus mu J in some sense the entry of
the covariance Matrix is capturing the
correlation between two coordinates of
course you have to remove the mean to
match the correlation the right way but
you match the correlation of the two
coordinates of this random variable
I saw some other questions
[Music]
um yes so x and z are the same thing
here I use Z because I want to be my
abstract so in a few in later I'm going
to have a little more I'm going to I
have to change this a little bit uh yeah
but this is just the for abstraction I
use a different variable
the second term is Sigma
here so here because there are scalars
so that's why I didn't have the
transpose so this is a scalar this is a
scalar right but and and here the reason
why I have transpose is because then
I need making Matrix
so um I don't know I think some of you
probably are familiar with this so I
don't want to spend a lot of time on
this but some of you probably not very
familiar so I I think I used to have
some let me show you some other pictures
to get a little bit more sense on the
covers
um let me see how do I connect to this
Maybe
do they know this um
how do I signals anything to them I
don't see they are capturing the video
the the screen
um
anyway
anyway these are these slides so it
should be oh yeah okay great so it used
to be the case that I make slides for
this part of the talk I just mix three
slides but then I realized that maybe
it's just easier for me to show you the
lecture notes because then you know
where to find them again right so I'm
not being lazy here it's just the uh you
know it's also easier for me of course
um okay so so these are some
visualizations of the density function
here so the first set of the just look
at the figures this is a two-dimensional
case right you have for these two and uh
and you visualize the density of this um
of the gaussian distribution so density
you know always look like something like
this right so and these are the cases
where uh the co-virus is analytic it
means that when the covariance is
identity it means that
so that when the covariance is identity
Matrix one one one it means that there's
no correlation between any pairs of
coordinates right like I and J with ing
another same they have no correlation
and and the results the
um the the kind of the shape of this
um discussion is always spherical so
basically when it's identity it means
that you have equal strength in all the
um like like a basically you just have
like a on the same strength in all the
directions because because like every
Dimension like looks the same in some
sense
um so
um so basically that's that's when you
um uh see this kind of like very
spherical shape of the density function
and then you can uh the one thing is
that the size of this density function
depends on the the scalar in terms of
the analytics right so if you have
identity then I think this is uh uh the
leftmost one but if you make the
covalents two times bigger then your
density function will be uh supported on
in some sense like a most exploring a
larger region so that I think that's the
uh the last one
um and then in the middle one you have a
smaller uh covert so in some sense the
covalents
um is
um describing how at least how large
this like how large this uh um this the
shape of this density function is and
also it's declaring two things right one
is the the size and the other thing is
that what's the correlation what's the
kind of orientation of the shape so
maybe one way to think about this is
that if you look at
um the second
like a rows of the figures so these are
cases where the covariance Matrix are no
longer identity and and they're for
example in the the third figure here
um so you have some correlations between
two directions and then you see this the
this uh this ellipsoid kind of shape is
rotated into that direction just because
in that direction the two corners are
more correlated so it's more likely that
these two chords are simultaneously
bigger or smaller so that's why in that
direction you have you have more kind of
like mass in that direction
and you can see that the the difference
between these three figures is that the
correlation along that direction is
bigger and bigger in the first one
there's no correlation in that special
Direction axis equals to y direction and
the second one you have a little
correlation so that's why it Tails
towards the direction and then in the
third one you have more correlation
um so so it's even more skilled in some
sense
any questions
so I guess uh
maybe another way to look at this is
that you can look at the Contours right
the
um the like of this thing so so
basically you look at the
uh uh the the level set of of this
density function levels that means that
the set of
um the basically the the set of like
points with the equal
or equal density right so and then you
can see that you get this kind of
ellipsoids and the same thing right so
so
um
um so if you have more correlations then
this ellipsoid will become you know more
tail towards one special Direction so
for example here I guess if you can see
my pointer so this means that in this
direction like a so I think if this is
X1 this is X2 right so if you see this
kind of Contours then it means that uh
X1 X2 are equally are likely to be
simultaneously bigger or smaller and so
that's why they have correlation uh and
uh and if you see in in this one then
you're gonna have some reverse type of
things right so if X1 is bigger than X2
is likely to be smaller and that's
that's when you see this kind of shape
um there's no need to you know exactly
you know like understand this right so
like uh
um it's just some kind of rough
intuition you know in reality you don't
necessarily have to exactly you know uh
visualize all of this but these are any
questions you know I know sometimes this
could be confusing sometimes this could
be very enlightening I don't know like
depending on
but if we ask any questions
okay
okay so
um okay so I guess we'll move on back to
the more messy stuff
um Okay cool so
so I've introduced the multivari
gaussian discussion and now I'm going to
go back to the gaussian discriminate
discriminative analysis so we are going
to parameter as x given y as a gaussian
distribution
so
so by the way I think I forgot to
mention that here in both of these two
cases the Y is always discrete
um you can you can make white
non-discrate as well but here we're only
looking at a case where y the label is
always discrete
so now let's let me continue with the
GDA
so
so as I said why is this great and we
are only going to assume that there are
two labels say one zero and one
zero could mean for example
um I guess I don't know why
oh I I think I missed one small thing
here but let me just
so I guess uh one of the running
examples we used to have for this uh uh
for this uh
gdr application is that you can think of
like you have some kind of like um I
guess for example cancer
classification
so like a benign a monument
so you have some maybe X1 X2 two
dimensional uh inputs and you see a
bunch of data like this
so so these are cases where you have in
eye cancer
think of maybe X1 and X2 as a
measurement right of the patients right
so maybe blood pressure or some size of
certain kind of tumors and uh and and
for every patient or every case you have
you know whether this is a benign cancer
or not right these are the the Bad Case
right malignant cancers so and and the
question is that you want to kind of
classify this right examples into two
classes right so that in the future if
you see one more example one more
example here maybe you want to know
whether this is a benign one or not and
the label is basically here let's call
this label zero on this label one
so that's kind of the the the the target
applications we are thinking about so
now I'm going to parameterize what is x
given y right excellent y
and I need to specify two cases where
one one case is that what is the X
distribution of x given y zero and the
other cases there was the distribution
of excellent Y is one
I'm going to make both of this gaussian
distribution so I'm going to assume that
x given y 0 is a gaussian distribution
and the gaussian distribution has mean
mu zero and covalent Sigma so here I
mean the high dimension okay so mu zero
is in Rd in this case these two and
sigma is in r d by D
and for the other one my modeling
assumption is the same I'm going to
assume this as Mu 1. and sigma Okay so
the same covariance that's just for
convenience I can use different
covariance Matrix but here I have to use
a different mean because clearly if you
fade a gaussian distribution to this
part bunch of points and you have a
gaussian distribution for these kind of
points you're going to have different
mean right so that's why I'm gonna have
mu 1 here and mu 0 here so mu 1 mu zero
Sigma these are the parameters
yeah so this is mostly just for
convenience and for like you can make
them not the same Converse Matrix then
um in terms of like the optimization in
terms of learning this uh these things
is going to be more complicated
um so it's still learnable
um at least with some Advanced
Techniques but it's going to be more
complicated so so here is really in some
sense a simplification uh simplified
assumption
this oh
um
oh yeah so that's a good question so
this is like this
so you're given this event y 0 it was
the distribution of x
[Music]
and that's a good question right so uh
so how do you model the accident y right
so in many cases you have you have many
many different choices right you have
different covariants you know you have
different means or you can even model
them in different ways so here I think
you know at least you know
um if you look at the data you see that
the distribution of X you know Y is one
and X gamma y zero sounds quite
different so probably it makes sense to
model them separately right if you model
the whole thing as a John Golson I think
it doesn't look like a ghost that's
pretty much the reason
okay who so
so are we done so we haven't done with
the modeling yet because we only model X
given y right before remember that we
also have to model P of Y
right you need to P of y and p of X and
Y to know the joint probability
distribution and then you can use the
base rule so how do we model the P of Y
this is relatively easier because P of Y
is only a distribution over two possible
choices right why I only have two
choices zero and one so basically you
just have to have two parameters right
so one parameter is supposed to model P
of Y is one let's call this V and then
you have P of Y is user zero let's call
this one minus V
what's the sum of these two has to be
zero so sum of these two has to be one
so
um and
so in some sense you say Y is from this
Bernoulli distribution
with parameter V
this is just another way to say this
okay so basically in summarize what are
the parameters so the parameters
I guess this goes back to the question
someone asked this question right so we
do have to have parameters even for the
general learning algorithm and the
parameters are mu zero mu one
Sigma
and Phi
and our goal our next step would be we
want to learn these parameters so that
we know P of x equals y and p of Y so
that we can compute P of Y and X
okay so the next part is about fitting
parameters
okay so how do we learn the parameters
from data right so we learn the
parameters the general principle
is
maximum likelihood
I think probably you know Chris has
talked about this word maximum
likelihood in you know probably once or
twice in the previous lectures but here
the maximum likelihood is a little bit
different I'm going to compare what's
the difference between this likelihood
from the uh from the one that we
discussed before so first let me Define
what maximum likelihood here means in
this setting so by maximum likelihood I
mean I first have to Define likelihood
so likelihood is this
basically the chance of seeing a data
given the parameters so it's a function
of the parameter
so if you have these parameters V mu 1
mu zero mu zero mu 1 Sigma you can
Define the likelihood of these
parameters this is the chance of seeing
all your data
foreign
given the parameters
so you hypothetically think that all the
data generated from this dispute
distribution and and you look at the
what's the density of the of your data
under these parameters
sorry
oh it's even bigger okay yeah sure
okay so and let me let me also clarify
the notation here so x superscript i I
think probably Chris defined this right
so we're going to use this through other
uh throughout the
uh the lecture lectures so x i y i
this is the ice example
so so we have this data set with other
examples I'm only I'm looking at the
likelihood of all of these examples
under the parameter V 0 mu zero mu one
Sigma so for every parameter you have a
likelihood and this likelihood uh can
have
this sounds like kind of complicated but
actually you can somewhat simplify it a
little bit because
um these examples are independent right
so you assume that your data are drawn
independently from you know uh each
examples are drawn independently so then
you can factorize this so this is the
product of the likelihood of all the
examples because you use Independence
P of x i y i
giving
and you can even factorize this a little
bit more to say that
you can use the chain rule to get P of x
i
given y i
and the parameter the parameters
n times P of
y i given the parameters
note that not all everything depends on
on everything else
um okay let me
I don't think I have a different color
so
um so here you can have some
simplification because y i the
distribution of Y only depends on Phi
right the MU 1 mu 2 mu zero mu 1 and
sigma are described are describing the
conditional probability right so y only
depends on fee so you don't have to
write here these things right because
they are the there is no such
dependencies and also the same thing x i
condition y I only depends on mu 0 mu 1
Sigma it doesn't depend on C so you
don't have to necessary write V here
even though you write it it's the same
so
okay so this is the
um the so-called maximum likelihood and
what you do is you want to say I'm going
to maximize
maximize this IL V mu zero mu one at the
same
so basically you say I'm going to
maximize so
um so the
the Learned parameters will be the
maximizer of this likelihood function
all right if you need to find the
maximum you want to find the parameters
such that the likelihood is the is the
largest
so this is the so-called maximum
likelihood in our context
so uh why the question is why you make
this independent assumptions
um I think in short you know if I I have
a very short answer I think this is
almost like always assumed in all
machine learning settings even in most
advanced settings and and the reason is
that um there I think there are multiple
reasons you know you can say this is uh
in some sense you know one thing that
you can imagine is that you do clock
data somewhat independently from a very
large pool that's probably the simplest
way to say it of course there are cases
that this Independence is known to for
example if you have interruptions for
example suppose I first get some data
from you and then I do something and
then I get some other data from you and
maybe these data are not no longer
independent or maybe
um the second time you provide me data
you also look at the first time
sometimes you know there's something
about this dependencies especially in
reinforcement learning like where you
have interactions so in those cases we
will drop this kind of Independence
assumption but in most of the cases we
do assume the data are sampled from a
large pool independent 2.
please find the stuff going right
C is a scale yes you are right and the
Visa scalar and is also a scalar in zero
that's a good question
do you have the freedom to change feet
yeah uh we are on the fee is a parameter
right so you're going to learn feet
You're Gonna Learn what is the right
thing from date so so how do you learn
free so you have to find out the
maximizer of this and the maximizer will
be when we for example some training
that's better using pictures
[Music]
um
you are exactly right you are ahead of
me yeah so and but we are going to prove
that we are going to show that that's
actually the solution so there's a
reason for that no you have the very
good intuition right the fee is pretty
much the proportion of the the positive
examples or the proportional positive
examples right but we haven't actually
so that's actually the case if you use
this black adults
is
right so the maximum likelihood is you
are maximizing
the chance of the data given the
parameters so the parameters are just
some you you look at all possible
parameters and you see which one which
parameter can give the light the most
likelihood oh right and uh so yeah like
this
so so this is the maximum likelihood
this is the methodology we're going to
use for generative learning algorithm
not only today's algorithm but also for
next lecture where we have other
settings we still maximize select and
just to compare this with the
discriminative learning algorithm there
we also use maximum code and but the
meaning of the the phrase maximum
likelihood could could be a little bit
different so so here you are maximizing
the so-called joint
the The Joint density right of both X
and Y you're maximizing the probability
to see
um the pairs of X and Y but for
discriminative algorithms
so for discriminative algorithm
so what you do instead is that you're
maximizing
the so-called conditional likelihood
even though many cases people just drop
the word conditional when that is clear
from the context so
in the conditional likelihood is this
probability of seeing the
the family of labels
conditioned on
the inputs
and the parameter state
so and you can also factorize this you
can factorize this as so here I'm using
Theta as a generic parameter just to be
abstract you know because I'm talking
about the abstract setting right so you
can think of this data as the linear
linear model family so and you can still
factorize this
you can factorize this into using the
independence
but whatever you do you always condition
X so X is considered to be a in some
sense a deterministic quantity You
observe you don't know how X is
generated we don't care about how X is
generated you just care about how Y is
generated conditional you see X
so
um and part of the reason why you do
this is that you only model y given X
you need to model what's the
distribution of X so there's actually no
way you can do the does this maximum
likelihood above in the in the in the in
the discriminative sets because the only
thing you model is why you can act
that's the only quality that you have to
parameterize form for so
um so so you just go with whatever you
have in some sense
um
right and it turns out that these two
are are indeed different you know there
are some relationships and there are
differences you know which we'll discuss
uh uh after I introduce some more uh
more examples I think
any questions so far
this is what we yeah
exactly
and and maybe you know I think you know
um
I think this is you know probably the
best discuss you know after I give some
examples of on the concrete examples but
in some sense you can see the
differences between these two kind of
algorithms and the differences between
these two type of assumptions is that
here you have more assumptions on the
all the data right you you are making
some assumptions on both X and Y and
here you're only making assumptions on
YG Max so so it's really about you know
home
like the differences will be about you
know how many assumptions you impose on
the on the structure of your data you
know how much like in some sense like
there is a whole universe right so you
you cannot model everything right so so
like so you choose some part of the the
qualities you can model and and the
decision here is you model both X and Y
and decision here is human model part of
it and that will cause some differences
in certain cases
that's a great question so the question
was that you know here for the genitive
algorithms we have the generative
learning algorithms we have assumptions
on the features right would that be a
problem if you generalize to you know
other examples so it depends uh it
depends on whether your assumptions are
correct or not in some sense right if
your exact assumptions on the on the
features is kind of gaussian then
actually it would provide you more
generalization generalization because
your assumptions are correct and I need
input structures and when your
assumption is wrong then it would cause
problems so
um so actually this is um yeah and this
is basically like the main differences
right so you
um for different algorithms you know
sometimes you can have it like as I said
you have a lot of variables in this
world right because can you probably can
even pick some other you know like uh
like so basically you have a you can try
to Model A lot of mechanisms or you can
try to only model a part of it and and
what's the decision you know often it's
a trade-off if you model too much then
you are risking to to model them
incorrectly right and if you model two
less then you don't have enough
um like you don't leverage enough prior
knowledge in substance right like if for
example if you really know this is a
gaussian you probably should not should
leverage the prior knowledge
um but but you may you may be wrong so
it depends the cases
yeah this is great questions
um I know I'll discuss a little bit more
about this more mathematical levels
[Music]
yeah
so so I think the question is you know
uh given to me and covariance you know
like if you don't know anything else
it's the ghost in the best is that
question yes I think that's a that's a
great question so
um so typically you know you are
basically right if you don't know
anything else then you probably should
just model them like if you don't really
know me me and covers but on the other
hand you know
um to be fair you know you know more
than the me and the covers right so for
example if you really want you can
compute the the third order uh
correlations between these data points
between these coordinates right so in
theory you can also because you have so
many data if you have a lot of data you
probably can model other higher uh
higher moments of the data I'm not sure
you know the definition of mobile so you
look at the higher correlations between
the coordinates of the data if you have
a lot of data um but gaussian is pretty
reasonable assumption and it's still
used very often
um uh sometimes you people use
transformations of gaussian so here we
assume they are gaussian sometimes
people use like you can transform the
Gauss in certain ways but gulpture is
pretty pretty reasonable assumption
so how do I do the test when Y is
continuous is that question yeah so
we'll uncover that but pretty much you
follow the same methodology you're going
to have a different prior or different
distribution for white P of Y right so
maybe you can model P of Y by
say gaussian again you know if you want
I'll
even have my variables to describe the
description
the accuracy
oh oh so so I guess the question so
um in short you know why the why is this
critical continuous in some sense is uh
mostly decided by your data set right so
I think typically if your data set is
really discrete right so if you really
just have like benign cancer or not
right you probably don't want to make it
continuous for the same reason as you
said you know why you want to make it
more complicated right so you have more
parameters to learn right but sometimes
it's just like your your why is really
continuous there's no way you can
discretize them or you know meaningful
way so
um right and also to be fair the the
parameters to model Y is often much
smaller
you have a much smaller number of
parameters to model y than the number of
parameters to model X for example here
if you come if you count so you only
need one parameters model y
right so even this is continuous you
only need one real number to model y
probably if you have say for example why
is the gaussian description but it's one
dimensional right so you only need one
parameter but for X it's a high
dimensional thing so you have to always
use more parameters
so so typically it's not a big issue
audio
make a judgment of how many
distributions
yeah yeah I think that's a great
question how how do you make this
judgment how many kind of distributions
right so the easiest answer is that you
always use two as long as you have two
labels
uh if you just have two type of things
you want to classify you just always
have two different discussions two
gaussians
um of course you may want to go more
advanced you know to say even for for
the maybe for the benign Kaisers right
it's not like really really like all the
deny countries are the same right maybe
there's two sub populations right so so
it does probably require a little bit
domain knowledge or maybe a trials and
hours you know you could try to
generalize this
okay so uh let me proceed with the okay
so I discuss a lot of methodology so far
so now the next goal is how do I
maximize this how do I maximize the
likelihood right so you need to you need
to be able to do this you know in power
quality right so to guide the parameters
right so this is about computation
partly right so what we do is we you
know one choice is that you just write
down this function uh in your computer
and you run some optimization algorithm
but you want to do a little bit more
than that in math because that will
simplify your uh your implementation
right so so we're going to simplify this
formula so that we can and and actually
we're going to do a lot of math so that
you the you don't really need a laptop
to your computer to compute the
parameters to to run optimization
algorithm for this right so
um
so what we're going to do is that
um so the first thing is that
we know that if you do a Arc Max
so we are we care about the arc Max
right the
the maximizer of this of DC so the the
maximizer is the same if you transform
your loss function
with any continuous monotone function so
even either log the maximizer will be
the same
and tip for the for the purpose of this
course this course we Define this
using a little L this is the law of
likelihood
okay while we are doing this no it
sounds like we just introduced something
even more uh more symbols the reason is
that this will make the product to a sub
so log of this product
log of a bunch of Paradox of range of
terms will be equals to
the the sum of the log of each of the
terms so this will be sum
of the log of these two terms and the
log of the product these two terms will
be the sum of the log of each of them so
we log of
P of x i given y i
um
plus the log of p y i
given I guess I don't have to write P
here
for this purpose
right so everything becomes a sub and
that's that's very important actually
because even you do this numerically
it's very important to take the log
because all of these numbers you know if
you do it empirical you see like there
are either very small or very big just
because you know we call that when you
have gaussian distribution there's
exponential here so it's kind of pretty
easy to see the density function it's
pretty easy to be either very big or
very small they are not never on the the
best scale like you can imagine but if
you take the log of it the scale will be
much nicer so so the log of the density
will be on like some reasonable kind of
scaling so that you can numerically use
uh and also it becomes a sub so you
don't have to do the product
so
and then how do we proceed you know one
option is that you again you can still
do the numerical stuff where you can do
optimization algorithm to to get the
minimizer but here we can actually
analytically compute the the maximizer
so so the maximizer here how do you
compute it
um what you do is you
I'm going to continue here so
um
so you really so how do you find the
maximizer so there's a small fact
I guess probably you learn from the
um the Calculus class so if Theta is a
maximizer
then that means that of some function f
Theta I'm being abstract here
um so then it means that the gradient
of the function at Theta evaluate as
Theta is equals to zero
so if you are in the maximizer you have
to satisfy the gradient zero and
actually in many cases this if after is
convex then this is if and only if if
it's not convex this is still
um this is still a necessary condition
so for us it's actually convex so it's a
it's a necessary and sufficient
condition
um but for other cases this might be
just only a unnecessary condition
so because you have this then you can
solve the the equation so you can try to
solve the equation
I'm going back to this is a small
abstract fact now I'm going back to this
case so basically you say
the gradient of the loss with respects
to all the parameters should be zero
right so like with back to three mu 1 mu
2 and uh and and sigma should all be
zero so basically you just have to say
by the gradients
is zero and this really just means that
the partial derivative with back to each
of the parameter
is zero
so now you have four equations and you
can try to find the solutions for these
equations
and and this is I think homework one
Q 1 T so in that homework we're asking
you to first of all you have to compute
what is each of these is right so you
have to have an analytical formula for
each of this right so what is the the
derivative of L with respect to Phi you
have to do some calculation to see
what's the derivative you have to plug
in all of our definition of this p is
two P's and you get the the loss
function as a function of v a new
derived the derivative the derivative
respect to Phi and then write out that
this is zero and you solve the equations
so that's homework q1d and this is a
little bit complicated to some extent
you know but not
it's still manageable and this is you
know they are even more complicated
things than this in machine learning
this is still you know but but at the
first time it would be a little bit
complicated because all of this has a
little bit kind of like complex formulas
um
right so and what I'm going to do next
is that I'm going to tell you what's the
solution of this directly so you know
this answer of the homework question uh
and I'm going to proceed I'm going to
interpret while the solution makes some
sense you will see the solutions
actually make a lot of sense intuitively
um and and I'm going to proceed with
that
oh my god did I switch to that oh my God
this is new zero this is thank you
so yeah so what's the dimensions of this
yeah that's that's a wonderful question
so I think often this is a confusion
that is pretty often like a um just
because sometimes in math they have
different things so in the in this class
uh the derivative of with back to the
the parameter any parameter will have
the same shape as the parameter so so
this is a one-dimensional parameter so
so that means that this is a scalar this
derivative is scale and this is the D
dimensional Vector mu zero so that means
the derivative is Rd and this is in Rd
by D
ude
so this is a zero ISO vector and this is
a zero Matrix
Okay cool so I need to erase something I
guess
okay so what other Solutions you know
so the solutions are okay I'm going to
first Define
some notations
so uh
select
u0
to be
all the examples that are positive these
are the index for the policy of examples
indices
and wait my back this is U1
u0 is the indices of negative examples
okay so under the mle solution the
solution will be the following so Phi
is equals to
U1 over n
where n is the total number of examples
which is equals to u0 plus U1
so what is this this is really just the
fraction
of positive examples
right so this is the fee you learn so
Phi is supposed to be the probability of
Y is one right that's your modeling
choice and it turns out that if you
learn it from data it will be exactly
the fraction of positive examples in the
data so so this is the most likely fee
that can join with your data which is
exactly the same fraction as in
empirical data
um and and of course one minus V will be
the fraction of negative examples in the
data question
okay
how do I remember this I have to
burn this in my head so one minus V is
equals to
this is the fraction of active examples
yes
one U sub 1 is it is the is a set
so this set contains all the indices
such that y i is equals to what
so this is the indices of positive
examples
Okay so
so for example suppose you have here
right so this will be the set you want
this will be the set u0
and and how do you decide what is fee
the maximum likelihood feed will be just
you can't common examples in total one
two three four five six and maybe 10
examples and you say four of them are
positive so that's why fifth is going to
be so in this case P will be 4 over the
total number of examples
10.
and
for some reason I'm going to write this
p as the photos I'm going to write C
also just to this is mostly just for
mathematical cosmetically uh you want to
make it look a little bit nicer in some
sense or more consistent with the other
equations I'm going to write next so you
can also write this as the following
let me explain this notation so this is
so-called indicator function so
indicator function
I'm going to write that one
of E I think I think the homework we
write it like this
you know people different people have
different type of brackets but it's the
same as long as they defined so one e
this is equals to
um
this is the so-called Indian function
for the event e so it's equals to one if
e happens
and is equals to zero
otherwise
so let me check whether this um so in
this case right so this indicator of y
equals one just means that if Y is equal
to 1 is equal to one this indicator of
that is equal to one otherwise it's
going to be equal to zero so so
basically this indicator is only one
when the label is positive and I'm
taking the sum over all examples
so that's why I'm basically counting how
many examples
satisfy y i is equal to one so so that's
why this whole thing is just equals to u
u y
it's probably useful to understand this
notation because I'm going to have a
little more conflict in formulas than
this so this is a four marking subsystem
this is just uh I guess on in my mind
this is capital
uh which is not the Greek lighter mu
um yeah I guess in the
um yeah when you do it handwriting is
not that obvious yeah but there are
completely differences right this is a
set another is a parameter no
relationship at all
um
why do I started
oh let's oh I see I see so that's a good
question yeah thanks for us so the
absolute value is um maybe I should
Define this so this is the side so when
you have a set
I'm using this as the size
of the cardinality of the set
like how many items are in the set
um this is the
notation yeah yeah that's a that's a
good question maybe you should take a
note on this I think last I was asking
this last time as well
Okay cool so I'm going to continue with
the telling you the solution of this mle
okay
foreign
this is the mle for the parameter mu mu
zero this is equals to 1 over
this is u0 the SEC the number of
negative examples
times
the sum
of all
the excise
in the set use mu u0 so so this is the
sum over all the positive examples and
I'm taking some of the the the input
vectors the the feature vectors x i so
basically this is just the the average
the empirical average
of X I's
you know of a negative axis
right so I'm looking at all the negative
examples I'm going to take the empirical
average of the excise in it and that
turns out to be the best estimate for
the means of that class
oh I see I see yeah that uh good
question so it doesn't mean anything
empirical average is the same average um
yeah there is you know just just think
of it as the average
there's some reason why I use that just
because
some other cases here sometimes don't
worry about
sorry
um
yeah
okay
so any other
yeah
so and and now I'm just gonna I'm just
telling you the answer and but this
sounds like very intuitive right so like
what would you guess you know what's the
the best
what's the best meaning for this class
probably you should just use the average
of all the examples
at least you know if you see it you know
it sounds somewhat reasonable
um and
um
you can guys you know just because these
are symmetric you know from the MU 1 is
the same thing you're gonna have one
over
the size of the positive examples times
x i
the
times the sum of the this right so this
is the this is the average
of positive
access
okay so and we're going to write this as
so I'm going to use this indicator
function to write them uh in a slightly
different way so I'm continuing
here so if you look at this formula you
can write this as the u0 the size is
equals to as we argued the indicator of
y i
is equal to zero
this is the number of examples where y i
is equal to zero because Y is equal to
zero means the indicator is equal to
what
right that's what indicator is saying
right indicator is saying is if the
indicator is y only if the event is
happening so that's why this this is one
when Y is zero so this this is why so
that's why this denominator is the same
as the size of the negative examples
so and then the the
numerator can be written as
equal to zero so you first have this
indicator only selecting those examples
that are negative and then you take
multiply x i
and for the second part
for the MU 1 is the same you just
replace Zero by one
so you have
and you have
you select all the positive examples and
you multiply x i
so you know why I'm why I'm writing it
like this you know one reason is that
you know it looks you know a little bit
kind of like more
um systematic I'm not sure whether you
agree with that maybe you don't
um another thing is that you know
um I think you see this kind of formulas
you know pretty often for other cases as
well so so it's probably good to unify
them in some months in some sense but
you know but you don't have to remember
any of this you know the I think this
this way is the best way to remember
them or and any kind of interpreter so
you just treat this as a cosmetic
changes some cosmetic changes of the
former
okay and
next I'm going to have Sigma
so the solution for the mle for Sigma is
like this
this may sound a little bit
complicated
okay so let me try to
so this is the what is this meal this
meal is the meal we have completed above
so you have to use the meal you
completed about to compute Sigma so
these are the means you complete above a
mean y i could be mu 1 or mu zero
depending on what what's what's y i
um and when we do interpret this is that
you just look at
you can
expand the sum into two cases one case
is the Y is zero and the other case is y
is one so when y i is zero so you have
the so those are the Y those are the I's
that are in the set u zero and this is x
i minus mu zero times x i minus mu zero
transpose
and then you have
you look at the those cases where Y is
equal to one and then this mu y i
becomes mu 1 and you get this
so this makes it a little bit easier to
interpret because this
if you compare this with the this is
kind of the covers but the covariance
evaluated on the empirical data so this
is the sorry on the on the data set we
have seen empirical is empirical is a
word that's used to stress that you you
are seeing the data sample data so
that's I kept using that but you we
don't have to use that word so so this
is the covariance
covariance of excise
for those excise in the set u0 for those
negative examples so this is the
covariance
of negative examples
and this is the covariance of the
positive examples
and and it turns out that the the
average of the in this sense is
is the is the best guys for Sigma it's
the it's the sigma that gives you the
maximum likelihood
Okay so
I've got all of this uh
parameters so far right so
um and now you're going to ask to prove
all of these are true and but suppose we
already got all of these parameters we
can complete them in near Miracle right
by plugging this formula because you
just plug in all the excise you have all
of the data you plug in you get all of
these parameters so you've got all the
parameters so that's the so-called
learning process you learn the
parameters and now the next question is
how do you make predictions on a new
example right you get the parameters how
do you make predictions
because
so if you assume they are different I
don't think the formula will be this I I
and actually if they are different
you can you don't even have a analytical
form
for the solution of the mle
like like the just you cannot Solve IT
analytically so here is kind of like for
some reason because we are making all of
this simplifying assumption you can
solve the minimize the maximizer of the
mle but it actually is not always the
case you can write analytically and when
Sigma are different for the two
subpopulation you don't have that
analytical solution
Okay so
okay so now we're talking about
prediction
so
let's get it
if you want to open
some water
but you want to understand you know what
what is the deny cancer or not right
that's your final goal that's that's the
final goal of the of the problem
so and the way that we do it is that you
say I'm gonna output the most likely why
so
I'm going to Output Arc Max
the maximizer of P of Y given to X
and the parameter feed
mu zero one Etc and note here that this
are the solutions of the anole
so these are not aperture parameters so
I in some sense you can even say I'm
obvious notation a little bit just for
Simplicity so here this female one mu
zero Sigma R those solutions that are
computed from this
farmers
okay this is a matrix right this is a
vector this is a vector
new theories of vector mu zero is the
mean of the gaussian
is a d dimensional vector
so did I say something here oh okay I
guess I erase it right so you assume y
given x given y
is from this you know from Y is maybe
zero this is from discussion with mu
zero and sigma
so mu zero is a d dimensional Vector
Sigma is a matrix
no that's T C is the is a scalar is the
probability of Y is equal to one
and mu zero is the prop is the mean of
the
mu 0 is the mean of x given y zero and
mu 1 is the mean of x given Y is one
how to do
this yep
Okay cool so
back to here so this is my methodology
I'm going to take the mle so how do I
compute this so it turns out that this
you know of course I have to use the
base rule to get y gonna X because I
only know x square and Y I only know why
but I don't know what is YG Max so one
thing is I have to use phase rule so let
me do the base rule for you and it's
actually simpler than you may think
so because here you are maximizing over
y right you are trying to Output which Y
is more likely right well it's more
likely to be denied cancer or not so
basically this maximization problem just
have two choices we are just maximizing
over two possible choices so you are
just taking the arc Max
of the two
the two point is two scalars they are
both probabilities
and
that's what
so just cover these two scalars
and which one is bigger and turns out
that these two scalars their sum is one
because given X in y can only be zero or
one
so
right so maybe let's suppose just for
for the sake of simplicity so suppose
you call this a and call this B
then a plus b
is equals to y
right and you care about which one is
bigger or the a is bigger or B is bigger
so if you have a plus b is equals to one
and
you're taking Max
of A and B
then what does this really mean it
really means that you are asking whether
a is bigger than point five or smaller
than 0.5
because you're going to choose a
if a is bigger than 0.5
right because
if 8 is 0 than 0.5 that means B is less
than 0.5
so that's why you choose a and
and you want to choose B
maybe let's write this again sorry
a if a is bigger than 0.5 because that
means B is less than 0.5 and it's going
to be equal to speed if a is less than
0.5 because that also implies
B is bigger than 0.5
so so basically
the question is that you just care about
whether a is bigger than 0.5 or not
so going back to this zone I'm doing
abstract thing right so if you're going
back to this then it really just means
that this Arc Max is equals to
1 Y is equals to 1 if the probability of
Y is equal to 1 given X
and the parameters is bigger than 0.5
sorry my
there's a little bit
and
limited space and if you zero if P of Y
given
Y is 1 given X
the parameter is less than 0.5
so
you know which also makes sense right
because you know why oh in my back right
so which this also makes sense because
basically this is saying that if the
probability of Y is one is larger then
you you choose y you choose one
otherwise you choose zero that's it
right I'm just mathematically derived
that for you
um that's it so
and if you look at this figure
so what's the final decision what's the
final kind of like boundary between
these two cases this line will be
the family of X such that
this P of y equals to Y given X is equal
to exactly 0.5
so if you if you define this family of
axis right
this is a family of axis such that the
probability y given X is equal to
exactly 0.5 and this is called the
decision boundary
so and
on one side of boundary Y is y is more
likely on the other side of the boundary
y 0 is more likely and the boundary you
know you just
do some arbitrary type of thing or you
just
randomly output what you know the
boundary wouldn't be very likely to show
up it's very unlikely that your Pawn
will be exactly the boundary so so it
doesn't matter that much
[Music]
so maybe let me just uh maybe let me
just uh quickly because we're gonna have
two minutes left let me just quickly say
what is this decision module is for the
gaussian discriminate analysis right
because here what I'm doing here is it's
pretty General in sometimes you can see
right I didn't really talk about what
exactly the parameters are and if you
really want to know it know what this
P of Y given X is but you have to plug
in the parameters you have to use the
modeling right so and for G for gaussian
describing analysis if you plug in
uh you plug in
um
so what you do is you're following so
you do p of Y is equals to one game X
this is the thing you really care about
so you use base rule so you say that
this is equal to P of x
you know
Y is one
and
here you only depend on mu one Sigma and
you have P of Y is one given
and you divide this by P of
X
the probability of x
this is the base rule that we kind of
alluded to in the
the beginning of the lecture
so and then you do a lot of calculation
which
uh I think this is homework
I do a lot of calculation and what
you'll find out is that actually this
has a relatively simple form so the form
looks like
1 over 1 plus
exponential
minus Theta transpose X
plus Theta 0
where Theta is a something of Rd
so that zero is a scalar
so they are
functions
or they depend on let me just simply say
these are Depends
on
V mu zero
mu 1 and sigma
so so basically eventually you get mu
all of these parameters and then use
this parameter to compute Theta instead
of zero and then you get y g Max and
that's your probability
and then you're on the computer decision
boundary
let me also do that real quick sorry
we're running a little bit late
so then you get a decision boundary so
so what's the decision boundary the
decision boundary is when this
is equals to 0.5
and when this is equal to 0.5 is when
this exponential is equals to one right
then you have 1 over 2 is 0.5 right so
when the exponential is equal to one
this means
Theta transpose X
I think
sorry let me see I think I need to have
a parenthesis here
but then we become some abstract here it
doesn't really matter that much so
um so it means this is equals to
zero
and and you'll see that you know P of Y
is equals to 1 given X is larger than
0.5
is the same as Theta transpose X plus
zero is larger than
maybe you say larger than zero
so so basically you have a a linear
function of X that's your decision
boundary that's why I keep drawing a
line here you know from here you know
from the principle you never know why
this is a lot right the principle says
that maybe this is a some formula of X
right that is let's separate this but
but the the derivation tells us that at
least for this case the decision
boundary is a linear function of x
they were doing protocol
uh so I think I'm gonna have this yeah
sorry this is a title here I should have
the parenthesis
like a
yeah I know the signs are not that
important
um
I think yeah we are
um maybe you can see with the best way
you can come to me to ask the questions
and I I can stay here is that the best
way maybe yeah